[Music]
good evening my fellow Americans
now before I begin I just want to say
that I know a lot of people out there
seem to think that I don't get angry
that's just not true I get angry a lot
it's just the way I express passion is
different from most so just so there's
no more confusion
we've hired Luther here to be my anger
translator Luther
first off concerning the recent
developments in the middle-eastern
region I just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people and
their right to a democratic process Hey
Oh y'all dictators out there keep messin
around and see what happens just see
what happens watch also to the
governments of Iran and North Korea we
once again urge you to discontinue your
uranium enrichment program
hey Muk mu kim jong after going on to--
both y'all 86 [ __ ] oh and do it for
y'all please test me and see what
happens on the domestic front I just
want to say to my critics I hear your
voices and I'm aware of your concerns so
maybe you can chill the hell out like a
second then maybe I can focus on sushi
you know that goes for everybody
including members of the Tea Party to
get me started on mismo right here I
want to assure you that we will be
looking for new compromises with the GOP
and the months ahead you know these
moste know before I even say yes no I
know a lot of folks say that I haven't
done a good job at communicating my
accomplishments to the public because
since being in office we've created
three million new jobs 3 million new
jobs the end of the war in Iraq and the
war y'all we ended
remember these achievements should serve
as a reminder that I am on your side
and that my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place they
come from Hawaii which is okay
Roper them with a damn in conclusion
last night I had a conversation with
Michelle
nope I did not say that I did not say
that
my fellow Americans now before we begin
I'd like to once again introduce you to
my anger translator Luther
hi oh this November I want each and
every one of you to ask yourselves what
has changed in the last four years who
killed Osama bin Laden what is my
administration accomplished do we
accomplish killing America's biggest
enemy check did that boom in 2011 alone
we created more jobs than george w bush
did in all eight years of his office
except for osama bin laden hunter
because that job don't exist anymore
because i went over there and I killed
his face we helped make health care
accessible to more Americans than ever
before I'm sorry what'd you say your
World Trade Center hurts then once you
take two dead bin Laden's and call me in
the morning [ __ ] this election makes a
decision that you think best serves the
future of this country
oh you can eat a dum-dum sandwich and
just vote for the person who didn't kill
Osama bin Laden but why would you do it
I plan to run a clean campaign one based
on the issues and the accomplishments of
my administration but I will take you
right now if the Republicans
bring it down a notch there look the
menu straight up out of control props
well it's not that bad
okay don't beat yourself up it's okay
excuse me Oh Wilfer you can't say that
word Oh
actually it says right here I could say
it whenever I want I guess I can say it
- good night mom naigus good evening my
fellow Americans
with me as always is my anger translator
Luther
what it do now as you know from the past
six years I've received my fair share of
criticism from the Republican Party I
can't even get Malia it allows without
Dimmick use to me a wealth
redistribution it's all part of
rough-and-tumble politics ah
in recent years I've also received a
good amount of criticism from my fellow
Democrats not you though I'm a bus oh
you lip now I know the right to express
one's opinion about the powers that be
is the very thing that makes this
country great look I got it not to do we
got a James Bond villain running Russia
I got a congress full of tea baggers the
earth is burning up and now I got a deal
with all these whiny-ass biotches from
party some have cited my inability to
make good on my campaign promise to
close Guantanamo Bay Congress shut me
down I'm a president y'all I'm a
president not a king they
check the balance my ass on me God do
and then there are those on the Left who
have criticized my continued usage of
you know what you can't have the
soldiers and then I mean what is wrong
in your head why would you compare the
President to one of the Lords of the
Sith
thank you and good night fellow
Americans I just want to thank you for
your continued faith in my ability
that's my anger translator Luther I want
to wish my opponent Mitt Romney well he
ran a good campaign now we move forward
with pressing issues we go pass health
care again
now what beaches while we had huge
turnout from our faithful supporters
thank you black folks we made it to two
elections in a row man all your votes
were crucial in this victory why do
people who voted for me you're all now
honorary black people so thank you for
your support and you if you try to meet
I mean you almost money to spend to get
rid of this million son I send millions
but you couldn't get rid of what I tell
you no hammer dance I don't want you
doing it wrong you gotta get it right if
you're gonna do it god bless america
I told you homeboy you can't touch this
[Music]
[Music]